did I ever show you our old videos Oh
videos if I can remember old band login
info all right here we go look well look
at how much more interesting and
multifaceted he used to be Oh hands up
we love hands up well the only job I
ever want to get is a hand job you'll
never see me doing some stupid old man
job and if you do please kick my hands I
wish I could buddy huh I guess those
days are over it is 38 million views a
lot I'm serious
well what is this why is all this
written in gibberish it appears to be
Swedish Jeff looks like you're a big hit
over there really look at this one of
these guys just playing all for you okay
Bali and look at this it says here you
can get stiff or girthier erections with
this one weird trick alright well we'll
look into this for one second and then
we're going to call those sweets